ladies and gentlemen thank you for
coming tonight my name is Michael
Fleischer I'm a sophomore history major
from Denver Colorado and it is my
pleasure to introduce mr. Bogdanovich
Peter Bogdanovich is a director
screenwriter actor film scholar and film
critic a recipient of several Oscar
nominations and film critic Awards mr.
Bogdanovich made his directorial debut
with the oscar-nominated The Last
Picture Show he went on to direct
numerous other films including paper
moon mask the cat's meow
she's funny that way and most recently
the great buster a celebration his many
television credits include the Emmy
award-winning HBO show The Sopranos and
an episode of The Simpsons he directed
the 2007 documentary tom petty and the
heartbreakers
runnin down a dream which won a Grammy
Award he's the author or editor of
several books including who the devil
made it conversations with legendary
film directors and who the hell's in it
conversations with Hollywood's legendary
actors please welcome mr. Bogdanovich
[Applause]
thanks Michael thank you is that Mike
here oh it's on that's right I'm not
really crippled I have to use this
otherwise I'll fall down because I broke
my leg a while ago but I'm all right
I just look like I'm not all right nice
to see you all
it's cold cold day today I guess it's
not as I was told from the inhabitants
who live here all the time it wasn't the
cold day today sure felt cold to me I
normally sit at the podium but I thought
I'd better sit down today because my leg
is bothering me a little bit John Ford
John Ford well I knew him for about the
C I met him in 1960 I knew him for about
15 years
he was quite a character I'll tell you
some stories I got a few stories here to
tell you the first time I met him was on
a picture called Cheyenne autumn which
was his last Westerner wasn't it wasn't
really the best Western he ever made it
was probably in his least good but it
has some moments and I was on the set of
in Monument Valley and I was afraid to
meet him and the unit publicity
publicity guy was afraid to introduce me
to him I said what do you warning
brothers had approved my coming there
and I was writing for Esquire and I said
to the publicity guy I'm the unit
publicist he said what who you who he
here to interview I said John 4700 what
do you mean no I wonder Brothers no no
no you see how he's chewing on that
handkerchief yeah that means he's very
very very very angry which is not true
by the way
so he wouldn't introduce me to him so I
hung around watch for a while and then a
couple of days later on a weekend I saw
Carol Baker who was in the picture and
her husband Jack Garr find a director
who just died a member and I knew Jack
vaguely not very well and Jack said what
he doing here I said well I'm Carol was
in the picture and I said I'm here to
interview John Ford but they won't
introduce me to him they're scared of
him
he said that's ridiculous so Jack
introduced me to Ford Ford was very nice
to me
sort of sort of pleasant he said sit
down and we talked for a while he said
to me he didn't he didn't say to you
Serbian he just said a dirty word in
Serbian to me go know which means [ __ ]
and I laughed and that was about it
the next day on the location in Monument
Valley there was a stunt done a guy rode
down the hill a stuntman and jumped off
the horse before the horse stopped and
handed dick Widmark a message that was
the shot so he did it I did it fine and
Ford said that's fine that's well print
that and he turns to me I was sending
fairly close to at this point we just
sort of been on the set and he said how
about that now I was you know 22 or 23 I
don't know what the hell to say he turns
to me says how about that so I said yeah
that looked kind of difficult he looked
at me with such disgust he just total
disgust and walked away and turn and
said yeah I'd say it was difficult
I'd say it was very difficult and he
walked through I said [ __ ] so I got the
hell out of there I'd stayed away from
him as far as I can stay away from him
about two hours later they did another
something else with the horse and so and
I'm way far away from him at this point
Bogdanovich so I run over to yes yes mr.
Ford
how'd that look that look difficult to
you and that went on for the entire time
I was there
difficult just one to see be thought it
was difficult now usually I'm gonna read
you some stuff I wrote here switch
glasses these are awful glasses you'll
pardon me but I look like mr. moto mr.
Ford was in bed which is he often was
when not shooting watching TV or half
listening to my attempts at a
conversation this is some years later I
would allow me to come over to his house
in Bel Air and I would sit in the
director's chair and he would be in bed
and watching TV half listening to my
attempts and a conversation even if the
TV had not been on mr. Ford's attitude
toward me would have been gruff and
lightly sardonic this was not unexpected
however since I would mainly talk about
his movies and you know and John Ford
would never allow himself to be caught
taking any real interest in a discussion
of his work or pictures in general he
was 75 at the time 1970 with less than
three years to live I was a 31 year old
director with two movies to my credit
one a documentary called directed by
John Ford
he had been in the film business for
over fifty seven years fifty-three of
them as a director only one decade
before Jack Ford got into pictures the
film business did not exist nor the art
of movie direction Ford had made 136
pictures the film business did not agree
med some of which in the 30 odd years
between 1931 and 1964 earned 72 Oscar
nominations
they won 23 including 6 that went to him
directly the New York Film Critics voted
in Best Director four times both
achievements still hold the record today
he had been responsible for creating not
only the screen personas of several key
actors most prominently John Wayne and
Henry Fonda but an extraordinary number
of America's favorite and most enduring
pictures
among them mean former stagecoach The
Grapes of Wrath how green was my Valley
she wore a yellow ribbon and the quiet
man
every so often after being consistently
edgy and sarcastic or soon after a
particularly cutting remark Ford would
would smile at me in an overly openly
affectionate way this might start me
waxing pretty soon waxing eloquent again
on some scene of his or asking some yet
another convoluted or weighty question
and pretty soon he would be insulting me
again Jesus Christ Bogdanovich can't you
ever end a sentence with anything but a
question mark have you never even heard
of the declarative sentence most people
were intimidated by John Ford his
appearance certainly contributed
Grizzlies grizzled face with one black
eye patch over a thick glasses I wore
one with my eye was bothering me and I'd
look too much like him so I stopped
wearing
a short cigar stuck in his mouth or a
portion of a long white handkerchief
which soon turned brown from chewing his
usual expression was either a purposeful
purposeful slightly sardonic slightly
belligerent deadpan or a scowl since he
always scorned talk of social
significance or of art never discussed
his experiences in World War two in
which he had been wounded and decorated
and spoke of himself simply as quote a
hard-nosed movie director unquote who
enjoyed making pictures as quote a job
of work unquote it was difficult to find
permissible areas to approach I
mentioned nervously that John Wayne's
birthday was coming up and that I was
going to thinking of giving him a book
giving him a book without turning from
the TV Ford said loudly hmm whenever he
wanted to humiliate Ford would feign
deafness and make you repeat several
times the thing you just said so I
repeated about John Wayne's birthday and
the gift I was planning a book for a
third time even louder
he Ford said mm-hmm I nearly shouted the
words birthday and book angrily Ford
said a wat I repeated a book then
suddenly Ford's expression changed
completely
becoming reasonable and relaxed oh he
said and turned back to the TV he
grunted and put a corner of the large
white handkerchief into his mouth he
chewed medet of Lee for a few moments
before looking at me again and enunciate
açaí slee he said he's got a book
when Ford turned back to the TV there
was a hint of a smile beneath his fixed
expression Ford's remark was not only a
devastating comment on a man he
profoundly loved and had to the greatest
degree helped to create certainly
without John Ford that never would have
been in John Wayne I had known Wayne for
five years by then Ford for seven and
the father-son relationship between them
was fairly clear Wayne loved Ford but
was still thoroughly intimidated by him
he was privately both critical and
frightened of the coach as he called him
or Jack the man after whom Duke Wayne
had most patterned himself Wayne once
told me his response to Ford on stage
coach the 1939 Western that had made him
a major star after Wayne had seen the
rushes for the first time Ford asked him
how he liked himself in it wayne
shrugged and said well you know what
that is I'm just playing you there was a
similarity in many of their mannerisms
especially the graceful way both
gestured with their hands and arms the
most the famous rolling John Wayne walk
was Jack Jack Ford's walk Wayne's
brusque screen character was Ford's in
real life but Ford was wasn't six feet
four with a strikingly handsome face and
ultra manly physique off camera Wayne
was gregarious warm and outgoing quick
to laugh strangely innocent Ford while I
knew him was much like the older
characters Wayne had begun to play in
Red River what the Western he did with
Howard Hawks in 1947 Hawks would tell me
that over the years Ford invariably was
erroneously complimented for directing
Red River Ford always nodded smiled
modestly and said thank you very much
Hawks put it succinctly I don't see how
a person can make a Western without
being influenced by John Ford and Hawkes
who never made a Western without Wayne
he made five of them was not being
generous he could as easily have
extended the influence to most American
pictures because Ford had long ago
become as synonymous with the great
American film as Jean Renoir had with
the great French film the forest and
Welles made his first to picture Citizen
Kane and the Magnificent Ambersons he
studied one film exclusively one feeling
said well Welles would tell me he had
run John Ford's stagecoach 40 times for
Kane he also hired one of Ford's
favorite cameramen Greg Tolin both
pictures and oh no small amount to
Ford's visual influence although Ford
was most famous for westerns he did not
make a talking one until ten years after
sound came in yet his career had begun
in the silent era and during his first
three years as a director Ford made only
westerns thirty of them nearly all
starring Harry Carey during the 20s he
made a dozen more helping to create
cowboy stars out of Buck Jones
hoot Gibson Tom Mix and George O'Brien
the first of his pictures to be a
runaway success at the box office was a
Western the Iron Horse Ford had released
in the summer of 1924 for his wife's
mitt for his wife Mary's Christmas
present two and a half years later Ford
had a new rolls-royce delivered to the
front door with a fur coat on the
backseat the note attached read this
oughta hold you for a while
[Applause]
he meant it and gave her no other
presence for many years the vast
majority of Ford's films dealt with
historical subjects the American
Revolutionary War and Civil War the
Indian Wars the building of the
railroads the taming of the West the
creation of a new civilization yet the
early westerns he made depicted
incidents and lives then barely 30 years
passed Ford not only made movies about
the famous Marshal and gunfighter Wyatt
Earp but he had known the man and others
of the epoch well well they told him how
it had been during the 30s Ford guided
Spencer Tracy and Humphrey Bogart
through their first feature and Will
Rogers through three including his last
as well as directed a number of popular
highly regarded films among them
Aerosmith The Lost Patrol hurricane and
the informer which for 1935 won for his
first Academy Award as Best Director and
his first New York Film Critics Prize
because he had fought against studio
interference and opposition to get the
Irish story done the informer turned
Ford into the hero of the critics and
the public he was already married for 15
years to Mary McBride Smith a
magnificent extraordinarily resilient
woman a direct descendant of Sir Thomas
Moore and they were the parents of a
teenage son and daughter and Ford's
reputation as a family man an artist had
never been stronger at this moment his
personal life was rocked to its
foundation Ford now shorty fell
profoundly in love with a woman of 30 26
to 26 named Katharine Hepburn
who also fell in love with him it
happened while the two of them were
shooting the film version of Maxwell
Anderson's historical drama Mary of
Scotland neither forward nor Hepburn
ever spoke of their affair but of course
the families knew the attraction between
them the explosiveness and independence
of both their natures can be seen
reflected in several of the key romantic
relationships in Ford's subsequent
pictures notably in the extraordinarily
rich emotional interplay between Maureen
O'Hara and Walter Pidgeon as the
forbidden lovers in huh green was my
Valley and between Clark Gable and Ava
Gardner who was nominated as Best
Actress in Mogambo despite their
feelings for each other Ford and Hepburn
came to a difficult and painful
conclusion he was an Irish Catholic
married to a wound in dearly loved and
with a passionate belief and family the
thirteenth and last child of Irish
immigrants his father was a saloon owner
in Maine Ford was now a famous wealthy
and respected figure in the world and
Katharine Hepburn was already well on
her way to the longest and most
influential career of any woman in
movies she had become a top star and won
an Oscar after her first Hollywood
season only two years before meeting
Ford and had been nominated again the
same year he won his first his her
reputation for integrity and Yankees
strong mindedness matched matched his
their first encounters were volatile but
Ford was remarkably gallant and
courteous courteous with women and
always pleased with and refreshed by a
well a well phrased and reasoned
argument when he made Mogambo in Africa
Ava Gardner was in the cast in the
picture and she came on the set the
first day before they shot and she was
introduced to Ford and Ford said you
know I didn't want you I wanted marina
O'Hara
and she said well you got a Bogardus you
[ __ ] in your hat and he loved her for
that and gave her every scene in the
picture he watches you see it's all for
Ava even though you know that Clark
Gable is the star but Kate Hepburn of
Hartford Connecticut and Jack for to
Portland Maine were a match made in
heaven but on the other hand they both
knew how badly their relationship might
damage their individual careers and
their ability to do what they had
obviously been born at precisely the
right time to do they both knew how good
they were and how much more they still
had to accomplish when he and my Hepburn
decided they could never work together
again they both would have known the
degree of happiness they were giving up
the decision a kind of glorious and
idealistic sacrifice is echoed and most
afford subsequent pictures the burden of
duty tradition honor and family is among
his central themes eight years later
Hepburn would begin the longest secret
love affair in picture history with
another married Irish Catholic father
named Spencer Tracy a liaison that
yielded a handful of memorable
co-starring vehicles and was not
revealed until after Tracy's death it's
difficult not to see a connection
between her screen behavior with Tracy
and her love not only for him but also
for Jack Ford the truly secret and
romantic one Ford and heparan remain
close friends throughout Ford's life she
also had a warm relationship with Mary
Ford that continued until Mary died five
years after Jack in the quiet man for
the single most passionately romantic
picture made in Ireland at age 57 the
Maureen O'Hara character combined the
best qualities of the two women who
apart from his mother
Ford most loved her name in the film was
Mary Kate within two short years of his
and heparins decision within two short
years of his after his and heparins
decision Ford would begin the most
expressive emotionally charged and
poetic series of film in motion American
film history between 1938 and 1941 while
America stayed out of the war at ages 43
to 46 for directed seven profoundly
affecting movies these three those three
release years were by far the most
productive of quality in Hollywood
Hollywood's entire history if any one
period is the peak was the peak for the
American screen it was the years 1939 to
1941 after which the u.s. entry into
World War 2 altered everything
it was Ford's competition in those years
included not only Gone with the Wind
which are in 13 nominations in 1939
against nine for three or four it's
pictures all released that same year but
a score and also a score of other
popular and critical milestones in that
that era from Capra's mr. Smith goes to
Washington to Lubitsch's dinochka from
the Wizard of Oz the Citizen Kane the
Academy nominated Ford
each year and he won the last two the
New York Film Critics voted in Best
Director all three years for its
constant work conveniently managed to
prevent him from personally appearing to
accept any of the ords this remarkable
burst of creativity began appropriately
with a Western although stagecoach was
his 90th film it was not only his first
Western since the advent of sound but
also his first in 13 years first western
and 13 years loosely based on a de
Maupassant story stagecoach began as
John Wayne myth and an established
Monument Valley which straddles Arizona
and Utah as Ford's own personal special
country of the West setting a standard
for westerns that only two or three
others including Ford himself would ever
equal or transcend his other two films
of 1939 starred Henry Fonda drums along
the Mohawk for its first film in color
and young mr. Lincoln the director had
had to browbeat the actor into accepting
the role of Lincoln in their first of
seven features together Fonda recalled
for demanding
who do you think what do you think
you're going to be playing the great
Emancipator or something this is a young
jackleg lawyer from Springfield for
God's sake the death of Lincoln's early
love and Van Rutledge and his abiding
faith in this in her spirit reverberate
through the picture Ford's other films
of this period are The Grapes of Wrath
Tobacco Road the long voyage home and
how green was my Valley in August 1941
four months before Pearl Harbor put
America in the war
Ford aged 46 went on active duty in the
US Navy with the rank of Lieutenant
Commander eventually becoming a two-star
Admiral he was appointed chief of the
field photographic branch a unit of the
OSS reporting directly to his friend
Colonel William Wild Bill Donovan though
Ford was even more close-mouthed about
his war activities than he was normally
about everything else he once told a
reporter quote our job was to photograph
both for the records and for
intelligence assessment the work of
guerrillas of adapt saboteurs resistance
outfits besides this there were special
assignments unquote except for his work
on several war documentaries winning and
winning him two more Oscars Ford would
not direct a new picture for nearly four
years decorated a number of times Ford
was also given the Purple Heart for
injuries sustained during the Battle of
Midway which he personally photographed
with a head held 16 millimeter camera
even after receiving shrapnel fragments
in the arm and groin the battles that
they were filming in Hollywood with Duke
Wayne were being lived overseas by Jack
Ford toward the end of the war the Navy
asked forward to make a picture with
Wayne in the line of duty
typically Ford chose America's worst
defeat in the Philippines as the
background to what would become the
finest and most compassionate America
American war films they were expendable
a deal was struck with MGM and Ford
demanded from Louie B Meyer the highest
salary ever paid at the time to a
director four hundred thousand dollars
and donated all of it to build a
recreation center in Los Angeles for
veterans of his naval unit the first
movie for directed after the war was a
Western shot in Monument Valley with
Henry Fonda playing Wyatt Earp and
climaxed by a recreation of the famous
gunfight at the OK Corral My Darling
Clementine surpassed stagecoach but
received almost no special attention of
the 30 yard films for directed in the
last 20 years of his active career half
of them were westerns Ford had realized
that the forum he had so greatly
influenced and almost single-handedly
perfected into an unique American art
could be the equivalent of the myths or
legends of the ancient religions and
histories of Europe as the modern
post-war world became increasingly
disheartening to Ford and less and less
interested in his work especially his
westerns
he continued nevertheless to explore the
themes that profoundly concerned him
unquestionably these westerns were his
most mature and resonant achievements
from the towering cavalry indus cavalry
indian war trilogy with Wayne Fonda
O'Hara and the rest of the Ford family
of players best viewed in this order
Fort Apache 1948 Rio Grande 1950 and she
wore a yellow ribbon 1949 to the
darkening increasingly tragic series of
Frontier stories that began in 1956 with
Wayne and The Searchers and they ended
in 1962 with Wayne and Stewart in the
man who shot Liberty valance
perhaps the two richest and most complex
westerns ever made affords 1962 Western
the man who shot Liberty valance is not
only ford's energetic final artistically
successful look at the American West
he had chronicled since his first films
in 1917 it is also unquestionably the
last masterwork of the movies Golden Age
which as I see it ended that very same
year 1962 remarkably prophetic of the
country's darkening future Marilyn
Monroe's mysterious death came that year
and John F Kennedy shocking murder the
father
year was only the first of the
modern-day assassinations the picture is
also a complex variation on what Robert
Graves called quote the single poetic
theme unquote a triangular love story of
two men in love with the same woman
they look water here based on a Dorothy
Johnson short story and historically
photographed in black and white the tale
is told almost entirely in flashback
Jimmy Stewart plays an aged much-loved
western senator who with his wife Vera
miles returns to the small town of
shinbone for the paupers funeral of a
forgotten Rancher John Wayne the local
newspaper editor is naturally most
curious to see as to why Stewart why
Stewart's distinguished American figure
known everywhere as the man who shot
Liberty valance a notoriously violent
outlaw played by Lee Marvin why he's
come all the way from Washington to pay
his final respects to a man no one ever
heard of Stewart tells him that tells
him in the story unfolds years before as
an idealistic young passive his law
attorney Stewart had followed Tom
Greeley's advice and gone West to help
bring the law their robbed and brutally
beaten by valance he is saved by Wayne a
prosperous young rancher and nursed back
to health by Wayne's intended a local
restaurant owners feisty daughter Vera
miles whom Stewart teaches to read and
Falls for in the process this sets the
stage for a complicated showdown between
Wayne and Stewart who are on opposite
sides philosophically about the way
order and law must be won as well as
being rivals in romance of course there
is also the showdown brewing between
Marvin's vicious balance and either
Stuart or Wayne a confrontation that
finally irrevocably and ironically
decides the outcome of the love triangle
the truth of what really happened and
how it happened and how Liberty valance
actually did get shot and killed and
killed is considerably different from
the legend we have been led to believe
but when the flashbacks are over the
newsman refuses to publish what he has
been told and he tells Stewart as he
tears up the
when the legend becomes fact sir print
the legend yet we also come to
understand that although Stewart and
miles have been married for decades her
truest love has remained with the man in
the pine box come to bury none of this
is spelled out in so many words and I'm
purposely not filling in the details so
as to preserve the effect for those of
you who haven't seen the picture suffice
it to say that the ending and the way it
is achieved have powerful emotional
associations not only within the picture
itself but in its overall relationship
through the whole of Ford's work
metaphorically the film concludes with
in America whose heroes are ambiguous or
tainted and whose yearning for the
wilderness for the watt for the first
for the time before frontiers were
settled remains its deepest passion the
man who shot Liberty valance is not a
young man's movie it has the wisdom and
poetic perceptions of an artist
knowingly nearing the end of his life
and career
Ford was 67 when he made the picture and
he directed only a couple more none with
the personal intensity of this one in
the score
he even reprises a musical theme by
Alfred Newman which he had used over two
decades earlier in young mr. Lincoln of
1939 a theme that was headed that the
themes musical theme that had movingly
represented an unrequited love something
Freud understood profoundly since his
own adoration of Katharine Hepburn in
the late 1930s also had an unhappy
ending I'll never forget the one time I
was sitting in the bedroom with Ford and
the phone rang in the other room and
somebody came and said miss Hepburn is
on the phone and I'll never forget it
touches you know the way he said Kate
and jumped out of bed to have the
conversation all the performances in
this movie are rich in our type of
reverberations the entire cast helps to
make this one of the glories of the
American
studio system with whose collapse it not
so coincidentally coincides and that's
my story about that
I'm trying them I'm gonna open it up for
questions in a minute what time is it
we got time for questions we do thank
you mrs. questions I remember now let's
go ask some questions because I'll
remember it shortly all right so mr.
Bogdanovich will be signing copies of
his book who's the hell in it who the
hell's in it conversations with
Hollywood's whoo legendary actors
immediately following this speech in the
Sur lobby we now have time for a few
questions please make your way to the
microphone if you have a question Thank
You mr. Bogdanovich you are a treasure
I I don't recall the movie but there was
a biopic about Spig weed and ward bond
who was about bouts pigweed yeah wings
yes wings of eagles and word bond
played John Ford right how accurate was
war bonds portrayal of John Ford and
that award was better-looking it was
pretty good it was was kind of cleaned
up a bit but it's a picture nobody's
ever heard of and it's again about a
love love love story kind of a love
story between love and duty the wings of
eagles John Wayne and Maureen O'Hara
very good picture very good picture but
a relationship with two people that were
pretty strong and how they got along I
didn't very good picture nobody saw it
but it was good what else
Oh sir thank you for coming to here
college over here I question the 1961 I
was in junior high school
and we can never figure out why Gene
Pitney song the man who killed Liberty
valance wasn't in the movie can you
answer that question no probably for
didn't want it in the movie because you
know everybody was putting songs into
westerns we started with Fritz Lang
believe it or not in 1951 or two in a
picture called Rancho notorious not one
of Fritz as best films but kind of
interesting
my name is Dietrich and there was a song
in that called fate murder and revenge
or something like that and it was it was
a kind of a song that was pretty
interesting and then High Noon did had a
song of course not mr. warden drew
anyway that was a big hit Tex Ritter
sang that and I think and and then it
became a kind of a thing every Western
had to have a song and I'm sure for it
said hell with that
in fact Liberty valance was originally
shot started to be shot in color and
after looking at dailies for a couple of
days for it said now we can't do this in
color the reason was because both
Stewart and Wayne and not no not so much
Wayne but Stewart and Vera miles had to
play younger in certain parts of the
flash' and an older and make up young
young make up or old make up for that
matter is [ __ ] in color sorry but it is
and in black and white you can get away
with anything so so we went to black and
white Network I've done both color and
black and white I prefer to call it
black and white by the way Lawrence said
you probably call me old-fashioned but I
think black and white is real
photography okay next okay thank you for
your presentation I've got a question on
the jondura
of westerns in general just the Western
most yeah and often that said that media
reflects the culture of the times in
which it's it's it exists right and you
know we had westerns like Gunsmoke and
bonanza and Roy Rogers and all this
western stuff at a time when the West
had already been won what was it about
America that has enamored with Western
motifs in movies and TV and other media
well I think John Ford was responsible
for creating that
affection and there were some very good
westerns made after Ford but Ford sort
of made the best ones and people like it
well it's it's it's the American saga
you know and the Western is kind of
emblematic of that and this simple story
good and evil who's that the whole thing
but the fastest draw and all that stuff
is mostly [ __ ] but but you know it
has it has a certain charm and it's
again it's like the old as I said in
this piece
it's the oldest kind of ties in with the
old legends of Europe as well so it's
it's it's our past being remembered by
various different artists and there's
been some good westerns made by other
people besides Jack Ford I mean Red
River Howard Hawks made two of the best
ones Red River and Rio Bravo and el
Dorados not bad either I remember and I
said two Hawks one time something about
Ford looked like it was influenced by
Ford he said I don't see how you can
make a Western without him being
influenced by Jack Ford I don't see how
I can make a picture without being
influenced by him and Howard was though
you know the last time I saw Ford he was
on his deathbed
he died about three months after this
and he was living in Palm Desert having
moved from Bel Air because his mad his
business manager had stole a lot of his
money so he had to move late at an old
age to Palm Desert which is a nice place
and he was there with Mary is why and
Howard Hawks called me he says I'm going
to go see jack in Palm Desert you want
to come see with me which was kind of
flattering I must say so Howard Hawks
and I I was a pitcher still and Hawks
was you know getting on only Howard
Hawks was only one year younger than
Ford but he acted like a kid around for
it he was like okay everybody was
intimidated by for it so we come into
his bedroom for its bedroom and
I remember I entered the room a a second
sooner than he thought I was gonna come
in and I caught him adjusting himself
into position that he'd struck a pose
and so we came in we talking and how and
Jack says to Howard Howard does he ask
you all those goddamn questions all the
time and hawks it he or does Jo how do
you stand it
that was that was friendly anybody yes
thank you mr. Bogdanovich for speaking
to us tonight I wonder if you might have
any stories to tell about one of my
favorite personal Western actors who you
had a chance to work with in last
picture show and John Ford did and wagon
master Ben Johnson you have any stories
to tell us about him well Ben turned me
down three times I want him to play the
part in the last picture shows a great
part for him and I couldn't decide who
should play it and when I finally
thought of Ben whom I admit on Cheyenne
autumn briefly I said Ben Johnson he's
perfect and I called him and I offered
him gave him the script and so on he
turned it down he said too many words
Pete too many words so I asked him and
he just wouldn't do it
so I called Ford and I said I got a
really good part for old Ben and he says
there's too many words he won't do it
and Ford said rgz always says that when
he came on the set and she wore a yellow
ribbon he went over to the script girl
he said any words to me today and if she
said yes he'd go off and sulk and if she
said no he just got to ride the horse
he'd be happy where where is old Ben
he's in Tucson
I'll give me his number I'll call him
will you I'll come for you so I gave him
the number and about 10 12 minutes later
he calls me back he'll do it
you really I said he said yeah I said
what do you want to play Duke sidekick
your whole life then come on Peter's got
a good Pete had a good picture for you
why don't you do it he'll do it I said
just that's great thank you so much
Jackie it's okay boy hang up now Ben
Johnson didn't agree to do it he came
into my office and he had decided he's
not too many words be it's three words I
said Ben if you play this part if you
miss part you could get the Oscar why
the hell do you say that he said like
that loud
he had the script open in front of me
and I said I don't know I just think you
in this part wouldn't it well he did by
the way and so he I never forget he
agreed to do it this way the script was
open in front of it from front anyway
all right I'll do the goddamn thing and
that's how he got the Oscar
I remember one line that one line had to
say when you go down to Mexico he says
to look to boys
you be careful don't drink any don't
don't be careful of that buggy water ism
and one of the Cowboys says oh we're
just going to drink beer and tequila and
Ben's line was catch the clap you'll
wish you hadn't drunk nothing and then
said when we first take Ben says you
catch the miseries you wish you hadn't
drunk nothing I said cut miseries yeah
yeah I don't want to say that other word
well it's not funny with miseries Ben he
said well I'm gonna say that other word
my mother might want to see this picture
[Laughter]
he said it finally I remember John Wayne
said he said to me I saw your picture
Pete that last picture showed Jesus
Christ I can't show that picture to my
family that's the way it goes my
question and pertain specifically to
Liberty valance and the love triangle do
you think that that is prior or the
difference between yeah the love
triangle do you think that that pertains
specifically to like the political
philosophical views that they each
represent or is it more of like the
romantic part of it that maybe pertained
more to Ford's life which do you think
like Ford was more attracted to in that
that's a good question
I think both I think both because the
Wayne character says you know you can't
make a deal with Liberty valance he's a
killer he's a vicious killer and he only
deserves to be shot killed frankly it's
what he just basically say and Jimmy
Stewart says you know we make him read
books and that's not gonna work so it is
that sort of conflict between one
approach and another approach and I
think Ford is ambivalent about that
because there are certain killer types
you can't educate and so it's a
complicated Ford was not uh did not give
political statements he used to say I'm
a political and he just wasn't you know
it wasn't his thing I remember one story
though it was interesting in the 50s
there was a kind of red end of the
forties early fifties a kind of a Red
Scare and Hollywood evolved into a kind
of blacklist people who were left work
were out and people who are right were
okay so if you were left ish you got
blacklisted it was pretty rough Orson
Welles used to sit said to me once he
said they betrayed their friends to save
their swimming pools and it was tough so
Joseph L mankiewicz was the president of
the Directors Guild and he and CB
DeMille Cecil B DeMille was the most
successful director in Hollywood
and in in the movies and he was pushing
for the Directors Guild to demand that
this that its members sign a loyalty
oath and there were people who
mankiewicz himself didn't read that
didn't agree didn't think it was right
thing to do and a lot of people didn't
like the idea but a lot of people did so
it was a conflict so they had a big
meeting of all the directors and Ford
showed up and he sat on the aisle and as
somebody said Sammy fuller director
friend of mine told me this story and so
did Joe's Matt Jill Mancos who was the
president he told me the same story so I
know it's true
and he said they said the Ford was
sitting on the aisle wearing sneakers
untied sneakers and a dirty jacket which
had food stains and cigar ashes all over
and and didn't say a word and people
were talking and CB DeMille got up and
made a long speech and impassioned
speech and George Stevens made his
against it against what what Danelle was
saying and there was a lot of
back-and-forth and Ford didn't say
anything they had a court stenographer
there to write down what everybody said
and you were supposed to stand up rate
when you raise your hand and be
recognized
yet to stand up say your name and and
slight description of yourself well this
went on for quite a long time about
three or four hours and four didn't see
a thing
and finally after four or five hours of
this thing for and finally raised his
hand and he was recognized and he said
my name is Jack Ford I make westerns
he said there's nobody in this room that
knows better but the American public
with the public wants to see and nobody
knows better than CB DeMille and he
turned into mill and he said but I don't
like you see me and I don't like what
you've been saying here today and I vote
that we I move that we give Joe a vote
of confidence and let's all go home and
that's what happened so that's an
ambiguous moment and but typical of Ford
he wasn't going to take the [ __ ] he
was going to take any kind of
dictatorial stuff and and to know
irritated him so he said it to him I
don't like you see me I love that that's
so-and-so Ford you know could you talk
about the relationship between John Ford
and Jimmy Stewart or Henry Fonda say
that again where are you I can't see you
did you talk about the relationship
between John Ford and Jimmy Stewart and
Henry Fonda
well Stewart and Sue and Floyd had a
very short relationship because they
didn't they didn't work together until
the 60s they did two row together and
then they did a little thing in Cheyenne
autumn and then and then the man who
shot Liberty valance and Jimmy Jimmy
told me he first met Ford he was
interviewed for this picture he
said that he you know had certain things
that he had a horse that he liked the
ride PI and he told for this and he said
there was a hat he wore in a lot of
westerns he liked to wear and Ford says
do you have had approval in your
contract
now Jimmy told me that story you have
had approval I said yeah but didn't know
what to say the relationship was good
pretty good there was one story I can't
really know how to win
Jimmy said that Ford told when he had
action to happen he would tell everybody
certain things but he didn't tell
anybody what it was they actually
actually gonna happen everybody told
everybody individually what they were
supposed to do but he didn't like to
give an overall speech so is Jimmy said
when Ford would say action the whole
plays things happened people were
running around and horses were loose and
Jesus Christ he didn't know it was gonna
happen and just kept going on and always
as he said all hell broke loose and
that's the way for it worked it was a
good way to work actually don't tell him
what she's gonna happen just let it
happen see what they do
Jimmy Stewart was one of the funniest
people I thought was the funniest person
I ever met
even his silences were funny his
silences were sometimes sardonic I don't
know how to explain it they may be
better but Jimmy was very funny and he
was funny about for a love for he was
very impressed with Ford and scared of
him like everybody else yeah it was it
was a good relationship he liked he
liked Jimmy Stewart how could you not
like Jimmy Stewart I have two questions
probably I only have time for one of
them so I'll go with this one I can't
hear you
okay well I can hold this I can probably
do better peacock and peacock and maybe
more peacocks in the Fords in the films
of John Ford what is the significance of
peacock as a name it shows up more than
once
that's one thing and related to that is
like John Cassavetes after him he uses
tended to use a stable of really
wonderful character actors again and
again and again was he the first to do
that
well they called that the Ford stock
company and they were he did use the
same actors quite often other directors
did that but not to the degree that Ford
did but but preston sturges did that he
had the same actors he used from picture
to picture because he only made about
eight or nine pictures yeah a few people
did that but not as much as Ford did he
like he liked to have this those people
around him that he trusted and liked I
mean there are two stunt men called
Chuck one was chuck robust and the other
was Chuck something else I can't marry
not Chuck Hayward and there was one was
called good Chuck and that was called
bad Chuck and that was that he had them
on every picture they would stunt oh boy
I miss these people they were you know I
was a young pitcher and I knew all these
older guys and I wasn't totally
uninterested in my contemporaries I had
no interest in talking to them at all
but I just liked to talk to the older
guys because they knew a lot of stuff
that the younger people didn't know you
know so I got friendly with with with
Ford and Howard Hawks and Jimmy Stewart
and Cary Grant Cary Grant was a great
friend they kind to me and very funny
Peter he called me up he said in in in
the in the 70s in the mid-70s there
wasn't no you couldn't open a newspaper
or a magazine without reading some [ __ ]
about submitting civil Shepard we were
having an affair
we were living together and there would
be some stuff that was very nasty about
nothing although all the time so Cary
Grant causes the PETA will you for
Christ's sake stop telling people you're
happy and stop telling them you're in
love
why carry because they're not happy and
they're not in love I said I thought all
the world loves the love
no don't you believe it
we have time for one more question I
recently watched rewatched your
masterpiece The Last Picture Show
everybody in here should see that movie
if they haven't seen it and okay can I
just take it you have to hold it all
right and I have a question you've
talked a lot about your influences
Welles Hitchcock especially maybe Howard
Hawks and you know since the last
picture show is I think you've even said
it's it's a very classically shot film
even though it's very modern and it's
black and white and it's not it's only
what eight or nine years after Liberty
valance can you talk about anything in
that movie that you worried about - yeah
yeah anything in that movie where you
would say you were consciously
influenced by John Ford I think I was
influenced by Ford period but I'm not
sure if there was anything specifically
that I thought this is a foreign moment
or something that I remember Hitchcock
said to me never use an establishing
shot to establish
and I sort of knew what he meant and on
picture show is a good example of it is
that the funeral scene remember the
funeral scene was when they bury Ben
Johnson we the sequence begins with a
bunch of close-ups medium shots of
close-up to basically of people praying
or looking down or whatever and the
preacher is speaking and I don't show
the establishing shot until the end of
the sequence
thanks to hitch but don't use an
establishing shot so I didn't have a
wide shot of the funeral I put that at
the very end of the sequence and it was
much more effective that's a good
example of my work of what Hitchcock was
trying to say to me he was a Hitchcock
was a great fun to be with and and very
I'm just the opposite of John for you
couldn't talk to Ford about anything
about movies or Hitchcock I loved to
talk about his movies or any a lot of
movies he liked to talk about how he did
it or why he did it a certain way so he
was a very like a real kind of a master
professor actually and I was lucky I had
a lot of sessions with him he used to
let me to lunch all the time always the
same lunch a New York steak coffee and
that was it so I hate the same thing I
said what do you want what do you want
I'll have it and it was always the same
goddamn thing we have one more honorary
question miss Stratton who traveled with
mr. Bogdanovich helped him get here so
she wanted to ask one last question just
what is the whole Ford accident happy
accident that happened in last picture
show remember give me a hint it was
where the Sun came oh oh yeah yeah well
that was interesting because Ford and
Hawks used to say the best things in
fiction that pictures happen by accident
and I didn't know what the hell that
meant
and orson welles said the same thing
best pig things into pictures have backs
I don't know what that means so we were
shooting picture show and there was a
scene by a tank damn where Ben Jonson
has big scene where he's talking to the
boys about how I used to ride across
this tank damn used to bet that he could
get it had a girl that he was in love
with it
bought beat him and so on and as we were
shooting and we got to the location was
kind of gray day not particularly cold
but gray and we started shooting the big
scene with Ben where he talks about his
past and so on and suddenly the Sun came
out I don't know if you said to me would
you like the Sun to come out and I say
yes we're here it's where it came out
and then it went behind the cloud and
came out again and the scene was quite
long went on for about three four or
five minutes and it came out and went
away and came out and it was great
effect and as it hey as it came out the
first time I looked at the camera
operator cameraman Robert Surtees who
was quite a distance away from his way
over there somewhere and I looked at him
and I went meaning meaning will will you
can you can you photograph this with the
Sun coming out and he went there's a big
help but I remembered what Ford about
there before it said it too actually
the best things in pictures happen by
accident he said the same thing but I
remember what he had said and what well
said so I didn't cut I let it play and
it was terrific and and it with the
whole scene was amazing the Sun came out
you know it was just very exciting and
there was a one problem Tim bottoms
forgot his one line that he had his in
the one scene so in the sort of toward
the end of the scene he had one line and
he didn't say it I looked at him and he
was sitting
and I said and finally he didn't say the
line finally I said the line out loud
and then he said it but there was about
a thirty or forty second pause and you
can't have 30 or 40 seconds it seemed
like there was no sign of Billy so we
shot it again the scene because of that
screw-up of the actor and he says to me
I didn't forget the line
I was acting I say I'm sure so we shot
the scene again and the son did not come
out and it was and we saw the scene it
was fine no pause but the son didn't
come out and the other scene scene was
so much better so the other take was so
much better that we use that and I had
to put in a cutaway to take out the 30
seconds luckily we had a point of view
shot of the field and so I and everybody
was looking that way our Ben was looking
in that direction so we could just cut
to the point of view for a few seconds
to get rid of the pause but but there
you are and that's the best things
happened by accident and they hadn't
told me that I would have cut I would
have said oh I can't won't cuz but for
dog ever said thank you
[Applause]